out of all the ancient helenistic
schools of philosophy the most famous
today is undoubtedly the stoics or
stoicism there are incredibly successful
YouTube channels and podcasts dedicated
to stoicism um a lot of you may have
read the meditations by Marcus Aurelius
um there are books conferences and
people who use stoicism as a way
to perform better at their corporate job
Indeed the exposure that many people
will have had when it comes to the
stoics is a version that is let's say a
bit shallow where certain aspects of
stoic thought is used to for instance
optimize productivity or gain wealth or
worldly success